tiger lost his tooth last night woke up
crying was like Dad get my tooth out two
in the morning I pulled the tooth out
he's like just he's crying I'm like dude
this is great news the Tooth Fairy comes
now you get money really
daddy don't have any cash so the Tooth
Fairy gave him a 50 gift certificate to
Starbucks so he wakes up this morning
goes dad what is I thought I was getting
cash two threads been working non-stop I
didn't have time to get cash so here's
50 in Starbucks yeah
when he said Dad
I got the Starbucks gift card what the
heck you should have flipped your
and then he goes no look and you say let
me see that and then and then you go
like this
the next tooth you lose
I'm going to wait up with a shotgun and
when I see that tooth fairy
I'm going to blow her brains out